if you're on a quest for some fantasy
netflix has you covered what's your
imagination itching for monster hunters
an evil witch a talking sheep keep
watching to find some films that have
all that and more
big fish is a movie about edward bloom a
man who's larger than life stories
turned out to be only partially
exaggerated when the film begins the
elderly bloom is dying from cancer and
so he retells his stories in flashback
form ewan mcgregor portrays a young
bloom as he befriends giants discovers a
hidden village deep in the swamp and is
attacked by a werewolf or working for a
circus bloom's son will has grown up
with these tall tales and has become
disillusioned with them but when he
starts to investigate his father's
claims he learns that there is a degree
of truth to all of them in the end it
becomes clear that bloom has lived a
spectacular life and the truth or
falsehood of his stories are
insignificant in comparison to the
immortalizing power of the stories
themselves big fish is a strange
beautiful film brought to life by
burton's signature off-beat style and
several fantastic performances most
notably that of mcgregor it also
features an academy award-nominated
original score if you haven't seen it it
should be first on your netflix list and
if you have there's never a bad time for
a revisit
trust me a man
if you'd like your fantasy films to also
be tear jerkers feast those brimming
eyes on a monster calls adapted by
screenwriter patrick ness from his own
2011 novel young connor o'malley's
mother is battling a life-threatening
illness leading him into conflict with
his strict grandmother played by
sigourney weaver and into an encounter
with the titular monster it's a massive
anthropomorphic yew tree voiced by liam
neeson in classic fairytale fashion the
monster insists on telling conor three
stories before demanding a story from
him in return as elements of the
monster's stories begin manifesting in
connor's mundane life the boy seeks the
monster's assistance in curing his
mother's disease
however the monster has a different
purpose in mind a different truth to be
drawn from the foreboding inevitable
fourth story gorgeously rendered and
even more gorgeously written a monster
calls as a modern fable about how we
deal with grief and the pain of lust and
a must watch for both drama lovers and
fantasy fans
if you like the idea of a fantasy story
with roots in ancient folklore but want
something with some whimsy turn your
netflix page to night books a film based
on the book by j.a white it is in turn a
modern kid-friendly retelling of the
middle eastern classic 1001 nights alex
moshe is a boy who loves writing scary
stories a habit that leads him into the
clutches of the witch natasha played by
kristen ritter who demands a scary story
be read to her every night trapped in
natasha's magical apartment alex must
use his imagination to keep himself
alive each day while figuring out a way
to escape but of course not everything
in the apartment is as it seems and as
alex grows closer to unveiling natasha's
secrets he must also face the ultimate
scary story the one he tells himself
did you say
scary stories
american author ailee martinez has seen
several of his books optioned over the
years but so far only one has actually
made it to the big screen that sole
exception is monster published in 2009 a
book about a modern day monster hunter
and the regular person who stumbles into
his life while the pandemic plague
chinese production monster run keeps his
basic premise very little else about the
film is recognizable to those who have
read the book that said it's still a
story worth watching cremo has long been
considered crazy for saying she can see
monsters but when she discovers a hidden
world in which monsters actually do
exist it turns out she's destined to
become more than she ever thought
possible the uniquely compelling visual
effects and imaginative world building
are what make this film stand out what
other movie could have both a
brilliantly executed time loop sequence
and the wisecracking sidekick character
who is literally a piece of paper
another well-known foreign film that
remains largely obscure to western
audiences is the mirrorboy a nigerian
film which was nominated for three
africa movie academy awards one of those
nominations went to edward cargatusi for
his portrayal of twelve-year-old tijon a
boy who grew up in london but is brought
back to his native gambia by his mother
after he gets into a fight no sooner
does tijan reach gambia however then he
is drawn away by the strange and
occasionally incorporal mirror boy this
figure takes him on a journey that will
see him reunited with his ancestors and
learn the truth about his mysterious
father while the question of whether or
not tijuan's odyssey and family history
are truly mystical in nature lies at the
heart of the film much of the plot also
involves a mother's search for her
missing son it answers that question
definitively as the story unfolds with a
magical meeting the mundane in a climax
flavoured with dark sorcery an evil
queen and the true nature of the mirror
boy himself
this list has recommended many different
kinds of fantasy but there's nothing
else quite like cosmo's laundromat an
animated short film created by the dutch
blender foundation it's the story of a
suicidal sheep named frank who
encounters possible salvation in form of
the enigmatic victor it's also an
absurdist masterpiece a beautiful and
bizarre creation that has no interest in
explaining itself and every interest in
leaving its audience in baffled
delighted or to explain any details of
the plot would do cosmos laundromat a
disservice it's a journey that captures
the true essence of fantasy
it's strange and wonderful infused with
the kind of magic that defies the limits
of reality and makes you believe
anything is possible even for a ragged
sheep who has given up hope anyone who
values the intangible truths of fantasy
storytelling should watch this film and
if you have netflix there's no excuse
not to it's only 10 minutes long your
time spent will be worth it
precious time
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite fantasy films are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]